[Music]
[Music]
this is David Deutsch man this is David
Deutsch man that's brother for the last
12 years David has held over 1200 babies
at Scottish Rite hospital hey David
when can I raise my voice after the
titles appear
[Music]
at Children's Healthcare of Atlanta
you'll find David volunteering as a baby
buddy a person that spends time holding
babies who were delivered prematurely or
requires special medical attention when
I first came to work for the hospital
and they gave me a little debut hold and
the Child Life person walked by and said
hey you hold babies I've got a job for
you
and I just loved it I became nicknamed
by a few nurses as the baby whisperer
but I'd be given a baby who was
screaming and crying you'd be amazed how
quickly they can calm down because the
babies stay in the hospital for a long
period of time
most parents can't stick around mainly
because their maternity leave runs out
or they have other kids at home that's
where David comes in David has gone on
to hold countless babies in the neonatal
intensive care unit providing not only
companionship but other medical benefits
as well just ask nurse Angie we find
that holding also can help mitigate some
pain so when our babies have heal six
done and they're being held they react
so much better than when they're not
held david has done this for so long now
when he takes a baby into his arms you
can see the baby relaxed because David's
so relaxed so you feel the baby's in
good hands
if you're a retiree I would sail you get
off your button do something volunteer
doing something and there are a lot of
different ways of doing it doesn't have
to be in a Children's Hospital I know it
meant a lot to the moms and the dads too
but what it meant for me I really feel
I'm the one who benefited
[Music]
so you've been caring for an animal and
you actually do have to do that little
bit of syringe feed and then the next
day you go in there to shrink feed it
and it wants to eat you you know you've
done a good job
[Music]
good afternoon tickles
Alyssa speaking how can I help welcome
to ticky winkles
the world's busiest smarter possible
meet Sharon Jacobs she's a senior nurse
here at tiggy-winkle z-- this adorable
Wildlife Hospital is named after a
character from a Beatrix Potter
children's book mrs. tiggy-winkle but
this isn't the place you take your sick
dog like France the British bulldog
right fly this is for all wild animals
found injured x-rays taken we do with
all British wildlife as in foxes Badgers
deer with mice they treat rabbits bats
big bird small birds and very very cute
hedgehogs the silicon swimming they get
around 10,000 animals through the door
each year with a wide range of
sicknesses and injuries okay this guy
come in to us about two weeks ago and
she fractured her tibia so we've
actually put a plaster of Paris on which
is a cast the Wildlife Hospital is just
like a human one luckily for animals
there isn't a waiting room any animal
that comes through the door the first
thing is they do they go through triage
so in lecture they are medically says
there see if there's any injuries if
they need a drip see if they need any
antibiotics painkillers and stuff like
that within 24 hours they normally get
reassessed by the vet and any sort of
like medical treatments or wounds or
injuries or x-rays or anything is
normally done then once the animal is
fully fit as in medically in sight and
we want it to go outside so there's a
bird frog mistake it we're going to an
Avery if it was a deer I go down our
paddocks and again once we're happy with
them and the aim is to get everything
back to the world we don't keep anything
because it looks cute and bloody
it's quite nice when it comes to
actually release from the animal and now
and again some of the deer will actually
bolt off and then turn around and stare
at your going so it is quite nice I
think the aim of tiggy-winkle is
obviously to save the animal's life but
also to educate people about how to
treat them how to get the animal back to
the wild if you do see an animal that's
injured to take it to a while to
hospital so it can get better
and then that way this little fella can
rest up with his cast
[Music]
[Music]
don't reveal character would address
some código not nosotros empezar compass
on purpose a person by veins or speak of
the knackers
[Music]
also a clinic around estas Patara
circuit printers nurses or spittle and
Stratton selection of sewers hospitals
Arsenal familias introduced which
becomes to emulate CNC trained he ate
our streams continual condors Bonita
Sandra not my personal orifices of the
agnostic taka-kun hospital Cheri Burcham
superficie
the boys viviendo cacao s season teams
solid solution par seeker
Tommy James memorial Keystone's Natsu
dosed organisms bhootish quizzes miss
with Sylvia save some spaces anxious to
leave the soil table versus doing semaj
frequent conquers Wyatt harvester
squeezes my Liberty dispatch screen
sister Gauri
okay so Empire is our sky two-to-one nos
vemos winters imagine scoliosis
mr. grant maryam nias a pretty Rock
Rockstar Aras improvement condos hasta
pronto bombs practice van honks car no
Elvis Pataki important some sushi van
katakana screw father important
prognosis grams are so that there's no
areas cuando intrigue answers makers
which assesses that Omaha Granada
preserve the
so dodged attempt crias if accomplished
and Ensenada
the our stomach mush contedner squash
book Nordstrom's canta dollars
[Music]
when I was working as a registered nurse
I was also traveling to many different
parts of the world and that's where I
realized that these hospitals don't have
any medical supplies to take care of
patients and that's really when I said
to myself I'm going to figure this
problem out and that's what I've done my
name is Elizabeth McClelland and I'm the
president and founder of partners for
world health our healthcare system is
extremely complicated
there are many federal rules and
regulations in our country and as a
result of that all health care centers
have to discard medical supplies because
they may have been in a patient's room
these are not used medical supplies
they're clean they're unopened and could
be used in the developing world I
started collecting medical supplies in
2007 and because there was no place to
store them in healthcare facilities I
started to take them home my seller
filled up from the floor to the ceiling
and it overflowed into the downstairs
bathroom until there was just a little
path that I could follow and then
eventually in September of 2009 I put my
money in to rent the first warehouse and
there are so many people that have
joined with us on this to keep it going
so it has a life of its own now which is
pretty exciting
we load the containers with fifteen to
eighteen thousand pounds of discarded
medical supplies we collect these
discarded supplies now from all over the
state of Maine New Hampshire Vermont and
fifteen hospitals of Massachusetts and
we bring them up here to our
distribution warehouse where we sort
through all of these supplies we package
them check expiration days and we ship
the container loads over to different
countries in Asia and Africa the Middle
East all over India and Pakistan and Sri
Lanka etc after the hurricane in Puerto
Rico we identified that there was huge
meat down there and so we are shipping
the fourth container of medical supplies
to be distributed in Puerto Rico
I'm dr. azouz Avila from the Department
of pediatric of Puerto Rico Sharon Oster
after Maria will lost a lot of supplies
that the scope syringes blood pressure
monitors is very important to us to
replace those to know people like
Elizabeth and the crew that just loaded
that truck and that container to bring
in here is very important for us those
supplies will be used to evaluate
pediatric patients here in our hostel
and even in our community health centers
we have a model that works so there's a
way to do this if I can collect one bag
of medical supplies now look what's
happened and so it's important that we
recognize that there are so many people
in our world that would benefit from
these discarded medical supplies so
that's why I'm doing this because it's
very important to me that we try to
reach out and be committed to something
greater than our own self-interest and
make a difference in our world
[Music]
a bird in New York City doesn't have it
easy
whether it's flying into a building a
car a bicycle dogs pollution lead poison
this is not nature's natural course we
have interfered with it my name is Rita
McMahon and I'm the co-founder and
director of the wild bird fund New York
City's one and only wildlife
rehabilitation center we take in birds
that anyone has found and we do our best
to make it whole so that it can go back
to the wild the atmosphere at the wild
bird fund is something of a three-ring
circus
there's the ISO room waterfowl room
reception area and downstairs is a whole
nother thing there are a couple of
hundred Birds down there they may be
flying around in the air as people are
scurrying around cleaning the cages
giving them meds and feeding them we
deal with 135 different species this
past week we had a Canada Goose 7
kestrels a rowdy bunch of juvenile
herring gulls this year 2016 we will
treat well over 4000 Birds
by being in New York City where the
animal is found we are able to save many
more animals they would die before they
could get help in another state or
another County people can come to you by
a subway or bus and they can get the
animal to you faster it's exciting you
never really know who's gonna walk
through that door or what they're
holding in that box I was at my store
and I saw the pigeon I saw that he was
like bleeding on the floor like pretty
bad I didn't even know that they took in
pigeons any animal that is picked up is
in really bad shape 50% will die or are
euthanized if we can reduce the
suffering that's a good thing too but
50% go free when the birds better you
try to return it to where it came if
it's an adult bird it might have family
friends it knows where to live the
migratory birds they're just passing
through you're really just trying to put
them in a safe place so that they can
continue their journey
[Music]
you